you and Devon had this moment about the
Klay Thompson interview I know book you
gave him the yeah I was in my feelings
though that b was bust my ass that day I
was not where I needed to be is there
anything that you would want to clear up
about that moment have you all been able
to speak I don't know where it took the
turn and me and Devon always been good
he was little bro when he came in the
league things got heated when we played
Phoenix and all of a sudden temperature
changed and this goes down to respect to
where now it's a line that was passed
stepped over the line me asking clay I
forget what question I asked him but his
answer was his answer you watched the
Pod I'm never looking to clickbait stuff
or have someone say something that's
going to raise questions he answered it
from an honest perspective whatever
Clay's answer answer was that was his
answer cool he took it upon itself to be
seen or heard in that moment now it is
what it is it's stuck if it's up then
it's stuck I think you're great I think
Devon is great I would love for there to
be some sort of resolution but as you
said things can always be resolved on a
basketball court absolutely